leute was geht ab ios oder markt
willkommen zum nächsten video hier aus
amsterdam
ich habe weil ich das problem mit dem
ton unter kontrolle gebracht sich
niemals zu den ton mit dem handy von
meiner freundin auf ich spiele heute
color switch das haben wir zig tausend
leute auf twitter empfohlen und die
beleuchtung bisschen behelfsmäßig aber
was soll's wir zocken
okay ich hab das spiel noch nie gespielt
ihr schnitzel heruntergeladen und wird
einfach probieren da mein bestes drin zu
geben
wir sind diese kugeln wirklich wir
schießen dir okay mal schauen was wir
finden den highscore am ende vom tag
aufstellen können man darf immer nur
durch das gleichfarbige okay wir sind
bob schätze kate ist es ist es jacky wir
probieren irgendwie mal als tageskarte
20 oder sowas anzumerken ich glaube es
ist verdammt schwierig wie gehabt bei 2
und macht schon möglich ansagen von
links franz i aber werden irgendwie auch
kleiner ich gehe davon aus
was ist voll schnee aber fünf hat er
insgesamt schon durchbrochen
ok doch wenn man so ein stern ein name
dann kriegt man in vielen punkt und
würde bei den anderen ändert sich die
farbe okay heute so ist der ganze unter
lang warten
okay das schon kleiner ist schon kleiner
leute ich finde das ist echt schwierig
und ganz viele angesagt jo appold
richtig nach dem spiel ich durchstarten
vor
ok ich hab's geschafft hast 25 wenn ich
schon das war es dann aber auch okay ist
wirklich schwierig wie kann ich ein
bisschen erzählen hier nebenbei was wir
gemacht haben in amsterdam mal wieder
keinen kaffee shop besucht
weil es wahrscheinlich wieder alle
erwarten werden nein die haben vor allem
gegessen kann man so ziemlich leckere
sachen also wir haben mit frühstück
barcelona also notiert total gibt der
kategorie müssten wissen
amsterdam ist die größte hipster stadt
ich kenne so circa also berlin ist
nichts dagegen wirklich was überall
diese streifen leben und kann es halt
einfach ich bin ich hinterher richtig
cool deshalb vorlieben bescheid so hipp
server ist oftmals eine negative
konnotation 6 aber das ist wirklich
richtig gut dass sich modern so so
ermäßigt und jage frühstück im café ich
hatte ein englisches breakfast übelster
wales flashback also hatte ich immer mit
luca dieses typische englische frühstück
mit bohnen und dieses vergiften sagt
dass ein bisschen und da hatte ich einen
raid 10 oberberg also tag hat schon mal
angefangen dann als leider anfangen zu
regnen aber ganz davon nicht großartig
beeindrucken beeindrucken er doch
beeindrucken lassen und es ist wirklich
schwer jetzt groß beeindrucken lassen
und dann haben wir einfach wenn man
ehrlich ist hat mir den rest des tages
dessen verbracht also wir haben uns so
von kaffee zucker fehlgeschlagen und war
inzwischen bringt hier dieser polina
holt das richtig cool finde ich von nike
und es gibt hier so eine kette wieder
mal kein verlag place mit etwas dazu
sagen aber es gibt hier so eine kette da
kriegst du also secondhand zeug und das
ist richtig cool also was halt so marken
zeigt eigentlich und es ist halt alles
secondhand und irgendwie finde ich das
voll cool so also ich nicht so viel wert
darauf dass alles läuft also hat aber
mehr dass es cool ist und das ist cool
und ich habe es für den pulli 220 euro
was halt und das ist nicht das erste mal
geschafft
dieses ding was zum spiel zu sagen
aber ja dann haben wir uns wirklich
kontakt info café geschlagen und
ziemlich guten cappuccino getrunken wenn
ihr da mehr zu sehen wollte auf twitter
verfolgen
das neue high school im coming
wahrscheinlich ich will gar nicht wissen
leute was ich wirklich wissen was ihr da
so für die vier dinger raus haut bei dem
spiel wahrscheinlich heißt jetzt 9000
aber ich glaub ich nicht aber ich würde
sagen hätte schon ganze weile wobei
einerseits sehe ich noch dann spiele ich
ein bisschen und leidet aber nicht so
schneider einfach bis ich mal irgendwas
vernünftiges schaffe weil diese acht und
so was nicht schon ein bisschen ist ein
sehr lobenswertes trinken oberfläche mal
gesagt habe ich es ja auch eine app
gespielt und ich mache es ja das hat nur
dieses ganze app spielen weil ich halt
irgendwie denke ich werde jetzt hier und
hat mich überhaupt nicht vorproduziert
man muss am main statt anbei möchte hat
trotzdem noch videos bringen bisher
eigentlich cool also hat er trotzdem
wirst du schon ein paar einfach gestern
jemand und sagt hey mister job so ein
scheiß spiel
holsboer technik und auch noch nicht
gekennzeichnet oder solchen so gut ist
nicht komplett verarschen
also ich habe einfach das spiel gezeigt
welche glücklich so zocke alles sagen ob
es wieder chic mit einer spitzhacke aber
einmal in der wüste scheiß spiel
schade aber einiges geschrieben von der
fake schlecht sind wie tesch nach mache
keine ahnung hat rooney spielt auf jeden
fall dieser typ meinte schlechtes spiel
und ungekennzeichnet das product
placement ich habe also bis mich nicht
verarschen also wirklich ich habe
betreibt die echten relativ große mühe
dass ich das zeug nach produziere obwohl
ich eigentlich
hier im urlaub bin und dann kam einfach
dieser larry und sagt sogar
ungekennzeichnet nämlich was ungefähr
vom konsens und ich glaube ist okay
cooler typ
also war ein bisschen blöd aber ich
würde mir ein bisschen gezockt und jetzt
probiere ich mal mein glück und melde
mich wenn ich irgendwie im einheitsgrau
gebrochen habe so schwierig da ich bin
jetzt haben denn mit deutschland es ist
so schwer
ich hab's gefühl das könnte was werden
orakelte herford ich meine high score
linie und ich habe sie erreicht das ist
voll cool hält es scheint mir ich soll
einfach diese passage gott was sie
schlimmer dass die fotos noch ein
einziges mal zu toppen
da es vor schwierig klingt war in den
variierenden geschwindigkeiten ist das
ist so schwierig dieses ding auch leute
leute das gut wir sind schon mal über
zehn sind über 10 10 ist gut
jetzt weiß ich warum luca dieses chips
gemacht am ende ist nicht schwierig das
kümmern wird sauer wenn wir diese spiele
spielt die 2
also übrigens bin ich bei sims 2 luca in
die wohnung eingedrungen aber ich lege
mir wahrscheinlich wissen
letzter versuch ich versuche jetzt noch
ein einziges mal den highscore zu
berechnen
und wenn ich es nicht schaffe ich hab
ich nicht wo ich noch gesagt haben
volle konzentration das ist ja das war
es glaube ich ich sollte nicht sein ich
bin schlecht in dem spiel wenn sich
gefallen hat last einleger und sie wird
morgen am nächsten tag tschüss